hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sally welt heute
gibt es mal wieder eine richtig leckeres
und exporte und zwar habe ich eine
riesentorte gebacken
denkt ihr wahrscheinlich was ist eine
riesentorte also die friesen torte gibt
es wahrscheinlich ein original rezept
aber das kenne ich selber nicht denn da
gibt es so viele verschiedene
abwandlungen mittlerweile schon davon
ich habe jetzt die variante mit mike und
streuseln gemacht man kann das ganze
aber auch mit einem brand tag machen und
ich glaube mit einem letter teig kann
man das machen und ich habe jetzt für
die hier entschieden weil die sehr
raffiniert aussehen und ist es mal
wieder eine richtig tolle torte zum
mitmachen und zum nachbacken weil sie
wirklich sehr einfach ist ich habe hier
unten eine website und der gleiche ist
auch hier oben sieht zwar ein bisschen
verschieden aus aber ich wirklich das
gleiche den oberen habe ich ihnen soll
ford stücke bereits geschnitten und
gefüllt ist er mit pflaumen kompott und
sahne und in den namen friesen truppe
kommt es aus guss fließt oder also man
eigentlich müssten wir jetzt dazu noch
im tee mit kandiszucker trinken sie
meiner you in meiner kindergartenzeit
warenhausriesen ist ganz ganz anders
jeder wollen jetzt aber keinen davon
hören also falls ihr wissen wollt wie
ist die torte gebacken habe dann könnt
ihr jetzt schauen was der tod hat nicht
verwendet für den mürbeteig brauch ich
240 gramm mehl 160 gramm kalte butter 80
gramm zucker eine prise salz und etwas
an den extrakt und für die streuseln
brauche ich 100 gramm mehl 100 gramm
zucker 50 gramm kalte butter sind halben
teelöffel zimt und eine prise salz
ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal den weg zu
bereiten und dafür darf die familie ist
erstmals alle zutaten hier in dieser
schlüssel rein leben
ich könnte jetzt entweder mit den händen
oder mit der küchenmaschine zubereiten
und ich mache mit der küchenmaschine
damit der teig schön kalt bleibt also
mehr ein zucker rein
ein bisschen salz und die butter habe
ich ein kleines stückchen vorher
geschnitten damit sie sich besser
verbindet und bis in lille extrakt und
jetzt lassen wir das verrühren
auf stufe hatte
ganz langsam auf stufe 2 und in der
zwischenzeit kann die sanierer schon mal
die streife zu bereiten
das geht jetzt natürlich auch in der
küchenmaschine oder ihr lasst einfach
eure kleine tochter machen als ich hier
hast du deine zutaten mehl zucker
das futter und zimt und salz und zimt
passt natürlich hervorragend sehen die
torte denn werden wir später pflaumenmus
noch mit drin und es passt geschmacklich
zu kommen jetzt mit den fingerspitzen
einfach zu krümeln verarbeiten zu
streuseln verarbeiten okay
und ich nehme ich den mürbeteig und
formen den mit den hinten auch zu einem
großen teil seien also mainz werde zum
richtiger teig und dein zweiten streusel
okay
zu groß für die zahnlücke
wer jetzt meinen website hier etwas
abdecken und für etwa 10 bis 15 minuten
in den kühlschrank stellen und bis dahin
ist mir auch fertig vielen streifen
zeigt es jetzt ein bisschen gekühlt und
jetzt werde ich in halbiert und werde
zweiten daraus zubereiten und zwar nehme
ich jetzt dafür eine klausur zu behelfen
nämlich dafür jetzt die back folie als
hilfe die nämlich zum ausrollen
wenn man dann einfach kein mehl oder
weniger mädels um ausrollen benötigt und
ich habe hier bereits meinen tortenring
auf 24 cm durchmesser eingestellt um mit
den zeigt sich größe des schottenring
ausrollen
da kann man den tod bringt einfach mal
drauf legen und dann seht ihr hier das
noch ein bisschen rand fehlt und das
drücke ich jetzt einfach mit den fingern
entlang flach
danke und das machen wir damit der teig
schön flach bleibt beim backen und eben
nicht so unregelmäßig auch geht
und jetzt nehmen wir die streuseln und
die verteilen wir noch auf dem teig
dann ist sie den teig jetzt auf mein
backblech und jetzt werden beide teile
gebacken und zwar bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 20 minuten
wären sie teil geht's noch abkühlen
werde ich schon mal den belag zu
bereiten und zwar könnt ihr entweder
einfach nur pflaumenmus nehmen es geht
ein bisschen einfacher oder ihr könnten
flammen kompott zubereitet so weit ich
das jetzt tun und abc die zutaten für
den belag wird ein glas pflaumen dadurch
den saft abtropfen lassen und
aufgefangen 200 bis 250 milliliter
traubensaft 60 gramm stärke 20 zucker
und ein halbes entstanden nämlich zuerst
einmal die pflaumen und zwei pc den saft
aufgefangen und muss den saft jetzt auf
500 milliliter aufführen und dafür nehme
ich jetzt den traubensaft
die sich einen teil des auf in einen
kleinen topf
da die stärke 1 und den zucker sind
stange kann auch mit dazu und berührt es
ist schön 5 ins heim
und dann kommt der erste satz mit das
tue und die mischung kann es tritt
aufkochen
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die pflaumen ein bisschen kleiner
schneiden
wenn das jetzt einmal aufgekocht ist
können die pflaumen stücke da gleich
rein gibt es nochmals durch rühren
einmal aufkochen lassen und dann dass
sich das pflaumen kopf und einfach so
ein bisschen abkühlen
die kuchen böden sind es abgekühlt
jetzt kann ich den unteren der dennoch
ganz ist auf einen torten retter ziehen
und ich lasse jetzt den tortenring
einfach darum herumkommt hatte ich
übrigens mit einer frischhaltefolie
abgedeckt damit sich kein haut bildet
jetzt müsste ich hier aus dem komforth
natürlich die zustande entfernen da
irgendjemand des flammen komplett ist
jetzt so weit abgekühlt dass es noch
lauwarm ist und damit ich es hier noch
schön einfüllen kann damit zentren
einfach schön fest wird das bestreite
ich jetzt und stellt dann für etwa eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
der kuren jetzt noch im kühlschrank ist
kann ich schon mal die creme vorbereiten
und dafür brauche ich nur wenige zutaten
ich brauche 400 gramm schlagsahne
was hat 250 gramm magerquark zwei
esslöffel butter zucker und etwas süßes
schnee zu integrieren
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die sahne
die kommt in eine rührschüssel und da
gebe ich jetzt vier teelöffel sein
apartment dazu und wenn ihr wollt dass
die creme etwas schneller fest wird dann
könnte ein viertel messer abnehmen
wenn die sonne dann steigt ist gebe ich
den quark meter zu den rühre ich jetzt
einfach auch kurz mit der küchenmaschine
und da kommen jetzt noch mal drei
esslöffel salat mit rein
aber wie gesagt wenn ihr wollt dass es
schneller festwirt gibt da einfach mal
ein zweiter vielmehr dazu jetzt nur ganz
kurz verrühren mit die creme festigt
dass du deine fragen
und was sind sie auch vergessen haben
ist es vanille extrakt die konzerne
treiben die creme stelle ich jetzt noch
kurz in den kühlschrank bis des flamen
kompott festes jetzt ist die torte gut
durch gekühlt und ich kann sie auf eine
tortenplatte setzen das geht auch ganz
einfach weil ich ja den mittag unten
habe der ist schon fest jetzt lese ich
den tortenring
und jetzt fühle ich die creme in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer großen stern
gülle und damit spritzig sie gleich auf
die tat jetzt nämlich nochmal den torten
einteiler und markiere nochmal die zwölf
tortenstücke
und jetzt kommt überall erst mal ein
dutzend drauf
und jetzt spricht sich die restliche
kremin so kreisende bewegungen in die
mitte als außen anfang wundern in die
mitte
jetzt nehmen wir die einzelnen
tortenstücke und setzt die einfach so
ein bisschen schräg oben drauf
bereits 42 ist die torte an und das
schöne daran ist man hat ja schon die
zwei flotten stücke durch wirklichkeit
uns riesen wie zu zählen nein bitte
nicht bitte verschone uns an
ich bin ganz schlimm als kinder muss rot
gelacht ich denke dass der deckung gut
schmecken wird weil man einfach dieser
knackigen böden hat und hier unten seht
ihr das flammen kompott und taxis die
ersten mal weise wirklich irgendwie
spekuliert ausgang medley aus ich habe
dort übrigens im schnee bestreut
der schein ist nämlich nicht an der
oberfläche und schließt landtag kommt
kommt nicht drum martin turner von dort
fragt mich bitte nix geografisches ich
habe auch schon mal die schweiz mit
großbritannien wächst
ok ich probier's mal also beim essen
muss ich dazu sagen mattsee trittin hat
wenn der obere mit trägt natürlich auch
sehr knusprig ist dann heißt com zeigt
wieder mal hier stößt da ich möchte man
hört es enormen mikrofon
man muss dazu sagen ich habe ihn
entdecken zu lang backen lassen also
eigentlich wieder nicht ganz dunkel aber
ich habe halt im gespräch
alle komponenten zusammen probieren mit
pflaume und mit sahne und ich weiß nicht
welche variante ich besser findet
flammen muss oder pflaumen com port ich
für beides super lecker ich konnte mich
fast nicht entscheiden
man riecht zum richtig und man riecht
und schmeckt so richtig schön guter
geschmack mit butter drehen und winden
streuseln ganz tolle potter streifen
spielt echt zu beruhigen und vor allem
schon wirklich super einfach gemacht und
falls jetzt auch lust bekommen habt oft
dieses rezept dann geht es - blog.de und
falls ihr die torte in einer anderen
variation kennt und sie auch schon mal
gebacken hat und ein foto ein rezept
habt dann könnt ihr mir gerne rezept
auch schicken oder und in die kommentare
schreiben
dann schaue ich mir eure war jetzt
nämlich auch gerne mal an und ja im
prinzip was schon da wünsche ich ganz
viel spaß beim nachhaken und ein gut
appetit punkt wir sehen uns das nächste
mal wollte ich noch sagen das haben mit
kommenden freitag dubai naja und
kommenden freitag genau da kommt auf
galileo ein dessert special mit mehr mit
logischen deshalb um 19 uhr
5 beginnt es 119 5 nächste woche freitag
aufgelegt auf totti